as Las Vegas considers its future as a
baseball town with the Oakland A's
apparently heading this way answers and
specifics though are in short supply and
there
and the questions about it eight news
now investigator Kyle Payne is here to
try and answer some of those questions
now that the excitement of yesterday's
news is wearing off there are a lot of
logistical concerns let's start with the
49 Acres on Tropicana where the A's want
to build a stadium it's right here
across from T-Mobile and should have
plenty of room for other restaurants and
stores you talk about Petco Park and the
Gas Lamp District in San Diego you talk
about the battery in Atlanta baseball
Villages like the battery in Atlanta and
the Gaslamp district in San Diego could
serve as possible blueprints for the 49
Acres that would comprise the future
home of the now Oakland A's obviously
different areas have different Dynamics
so it says economic analyst Jeremy
Aguero who the A's have hired to examine
the dollars and cents behind the
enormous move of a professional baseball
team from the Bay Area Tropicana Ave at
potential site not only includes an area
where they can develop a stadium but
also includes an area where they can
build out a baseball or a sports and
entertainment District a district like
the one they built around T-Mobile Arena
where the NHL's Golden Knights Play
Aguero says the new stadium will be
state of the art and so will what he
calls the baseball Village the A's will
build around it the stadium only takes
up 9 to 13 acres leaving another 40 or
so acres for shops and restaurants what
has been discussed is that it would be
world class and Aguero would know if
there's a big deal happening in Vegas
he's probably looking at the numbers
he's had a hand in helping bring to Las
Vegas the Raiders and their Stadium F1
racing Tesla and now the A's that's kind
of a big deal for us a big deal with big
questions who will make up the work for
us what about all that water what will
the traffic be like and where will
everyone Park it's a question not only
for the A's but also for Clark County
we've had conversations with the county
I know the county is going to have to
make some hard decisions Jim Gibson is
Chairman of the Clark County Commission
he says if history is any guide the
legislature and Governor will set some
guidelines and give the county
parameters you can use these parameters
to Fashion a deal but Gibson says not
just yet right now we just don't know
enough detail the answer to these
questions do lie in the details we were
at their spot they were talking about
building the ballpark yesterday one of
the Oakland A's could probably throw a
ball from there to T-Mobile Arena so
there could be two pro sports Villages
right next to each other
could be but there are still a lot few
years actually before this happens
because the A's aren't expecting a new
ballpark to be built and ready for them
until 2027. so in the meantime it looks
like the A's will spend a few seasons
playing at the Las Vegas ballpark in
Summerlin